I was a man of the year in 1986 it was
me ET spuds McKenzie Diomed for glory
and then what else she had a fig who's a
womanizer he was you know I can believe
it yeah a real step back but now we're
in 2015 you're men of the year I did not
make it into men of the year this year
we should swamp what advice you guys
have to be men of the year man listen
like seriously you better have
confidence go be yourself y'all just
like walk into the party or whatever and
just own it
just be yourself what do I bring I'm
pretty wack that's what I bring like
wackyland anybody else confident being
yourself and being wack
seneschal you guys are creating Donald
Trump Donald Trump of the [ __ ] night
at the man of the year you guys would
put you Frankenstein Donald Trump that
was you know what the intention perfume
apparently dance call me being GQ Men of
the Year you guys are allowed to kill
anybody here at this party so have at it
have a great time anybody you can choke
them out you can throw them in the pool
no consequences congratulations review
dangerous dangerous shits at the table
my friend I love it